[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
you may think it's funny [ __ ]
but i don't find it funny
[Music]
a quote
that will define this midterm
bet o'rourke in texas last night at one
of his rallies
some trumped-up [ __ ] greg abbott
supporter some old white dude of course
it is some a white dude in the corner
or the greg abbott sign
starts laughing as bet o'rourke
describes what happened to 19 children
and two teachers that were slaughtered
in the robb elementary school in uvalde
texas laughing hahaha it's funny he says
and better roark
wads him up and dunks him in the [ __ ]
trash with one sentence the entire room
erupts i can't stop watching the [ __ ]
video i can't stop watching it folks the
tide is turning
it's turning
pro democracy people are [ __ ] sick
of this nonsense just the absolute vile
nonsense
and better roar does not give two [ __ ]
if you think that his words are
offensive he does not give a [ __ ] he's
fighting for the people in texas and
that is key here folks that is
absolutely key every single word that
comes out of bet o'rourke's mouth is
about community have you noticed that
every single word that comes out of tim
ryan's mouth in ohio is about community
every word that comes out of fetterman's
mouth in pennsylvania is about their
community
they have divided us up put wedges
between us for far too long
we are a community this is a democracy
that's what this is
and you may think it's funny
[ __ ]
but i don't think it's that funny and
that's the quote that's the attitude
that's what we have to bring
to this midterm and probably the next
election election after that it's enough
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] i've been saying
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em for two goddamn
years
and it's starting to catch on
it's starting to catch on folks because
it's enough of this nonsense and the
[ __ ]
that we have to put up with a bunch of
[ __ ] trolls running around our
country go climb back underneath the
[ __ ] rocks you crawled out from you
[ __ ] nazis it's enough of this
[ __ ]
some [ __ ] idiot from new york city
who thinks he's great at building
buildings he's great at laundering
russian's money
decides to give permission to a bunch of
dumb [ __ ] in this country and we're not
gonna put up with it this is democracy
[ __ ] this is our democracy this is our
country go climb back underneath your
[ __ ] rock
we're gonna run this [ __ ] here it's
ours not yours you dumbass
better orc was having none of that [ __ ]
absolutely [ __ ] none of it
absolutely none of it and i know here on
the tony michaels podcast we have plenty
of listeners
who are in the state of texas and who
have the ability to make their voice
heard
this november
and slam dunk greg abbott in the trash
where he [ __ ] belongs that piece of
garbage
having his supporters go out and troll
better roarick's events
and
i didn't turn out so well did it dummy
so i implore you if you're in texas
engage in your ballot and i don't just
mean going and marking the ballot for
beto you know that
you know that i know that's the most
important thing
that's at the top of the priority list
is to mark your ballot for the correct
candidates that are for democracy that
are for your state that are for your
community
that are ready to do the things
and implement the policy that helps the
people in your community
enough of this [ __ ] billy jack
[ __ ] from the nra
the pro-life movement those [ __ ]
force birthers it's enough of this [ __ ]
you have to do more you have to knock
doors contact people talk to your family
talk to your friends
there are so many videos
of trump supporters going to bedo's
rallies and when he starts to talk about
community folks just like we do here
when he starts to talk about what is
important to their community
they listen and they turn i watched a
video where he is signing
a make america great again hat
the best trolling in the [ __ ]
world when beto o'rourke signs the bill
of a make america great again cap
how about that donald trump
how about that
we got them on their heels folks we
can't we gotta lean into it i mean we
gotta lean way into this just like beto
did last night
at that [ __ ] laughing at 19
children getting ripped apart
by a weapon of war just lean into it
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them it's enough of it
it's our country it's our government
it's our vote
it's our policies we get to [ __ ]
decide not you fascist [ __ ]
telling us what to do and putting your
big government [ __ ] all up in
women's uteruses all up in our houses
all up in our gender and our pronouns
jesus christ they can't even they can't
even figure out what the [ __ ] a pronoun
even is
it's enough of the [ __ ] it's not for the
[ __ ] i'm tired of hearing it and i
know you are too and i know most
americans are tired of the [ __ ] real
life and wrestlemania [ __ ]
because that's what we're at we're at
the intersection of wrestlemania in real
life folks it's a goddamn reality show
to these dumb [ __ ] they have no
clue that this is real life [ __ ]
this affects real people
their pocketbooks their homes their
families their lives
laughing at 19 [ __ ] children getting
slaughtered in uvalde in texas laughing
at
he's holding an ad at a greg abbott sign
of course he's laughing
of course he's laughing at that
it just shows you what his greg abbott
supporters are left with
the bottom of the [ __ ] barrel the
scum of the scum
that's all they can attract that's all
they got
is the worthless pieces of [ __ ] that
don't know their head from shinola
it's time
you can do it we can do it we just have
to gather up together we have to
organize we have to again lean into
democracy because they are terrified of
democracy folks
have you been watching these right
wingers freaked the [ __ ] out
freak the [ __ ] out marjorie taylor green
is scared she's gonna get her phone
seized scott perry got his seized margie
taylor green's freaking out
they're all freaking out like oh my god
oh my god
well can you imagine under trump
if they if they raided obama and took
over aoc's [ __ ] yeah the fbi wouldn't
rate obama or take a aoc's phone
they wouldn't because they're not
[ __ ] criminals as much as you hate
them and you hate their ideas they're
not criminals that's the difference you
[ __ ] morons i don't know who this guy
running for senate is who said this [ __ ]
i know he tweeted
i know we'll we'll get to it today but
he tweets what if trump would have had
obama raided
what are you talking about see that
right there you don't understand how
democracies work how the department of
justice work and how the fbi works
clearly you are not qualified to be in
senate whatever the [ __ ] this guy's name
is i don't know what the [ __ ] his name
is does it really matter what his name
is
trump number 142 let's just call it that
he's some probably some [ __ ] trump
endorsed uh candidate for senate
what if what if what if trim pedo bama's
house right see again you are an
authoritarian you are a fascist
because your brain automatically thinks
that that is how it works you [ __ ]
boneheads that is not how it [ __ ]
works
the president united states doesn't have
a gasoline button on his desk and he
doesn't have an fbi raid button on his
desk
people are [ __ ] brain dead you need
you need to [ __ ] seek some help
it's getting ridiculous that you can't
even [ __ ] figure out how government
and our institutions work how the [ __ ]
are you expected to go to
our [ __ ] capitol in our [ __ ]
capitol building on the senate floor
and we expect you to to create policy
and pass policy and you don't even know
that the president united states doesn't
have the power just to raid anybody they
want you are a dumb [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] and it only it only
is a is a is a [ __ ] signal
of what these people want they want
authoritarianism
they wanted trump to raid obama for no
[ __ ] reason other than trump hates
him and his supporters hate him lock him
up put him in jail
that's not what has happened here
i mean jesus christ the raid even had
nothing to do with the highest crimes
that trump's committed trump has
committed treason as far as i'm
concerned
you look at what has happened in january
6 and just the evidence that's coming
out of the select committee now you have
scott perry
getting his cell phone seized a member
of congress folks
after
john eastman who was the architect of
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
in the state of fake state electors
scheme
scott perry was probably carrying those
[ __ ] state electors around in his
goddamn coat pocket
i don't know i'm not saying he was i'm
just saying there's a reason why they
seized his [ __ ] cell phone folks
and it just seems convenient that
weeks after jeffrey clark and john
eastman have their [ __ ] taken have their
[ __ ] lifted by the fbi
it just seems convenient maybe it took
him a few weeks to get through it and
find another treasonous piece of [ __ ]
who's a member of congress scott perry
and we're probably going to see more
members of congress
ronnie jackson being one of them i'm not
kidding you i'm telling you the
[ __ ] had something he was trying
to seek protection from the oath keepers
on the day of the sixth
to protect data he had and i doubt i
doubt it was the real weight of donald
trump that he was trying to protect that
kind of data [ __ ]
i would almost bet that that ronnie
jackson was carrying around fake state
electors that's the data
that's the envelope for full of
information that they needed protection
they were protecting the crime
it's becoming more and more clear and
more and more obvious and i'm sure folks
like marjorie taylor green paul goes-r
andy bigs some of these other treasonous
pieces of [ __ ] they're freaking the [ __ ]
out
they're probably trying to delete [ __ ]
off their cell phones i can't even
[ __ ] imagine which is another [ __ ]
crime
another crime
and speaking of deleted emails we know
now that the dod was scrubbing all this
[ __ ] to cover it up
he's a [ __ ] criminal
he's a [ __ ] criminal and the rest of
them are [ __ ] criminals
and again you may think it's funny
[ __ ] you may think it's funny oh
the january 6 was a great day in
american history
it's so funny
it's not [ __ ] funny [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] funny
it's our democracy it's our government
it's our way of life you stupid piece of
[ __ ] it's our way of life it's ours not
yours it's ours it's everyone's
you know just because you don't get the
result you want doesn't mean you get to
whine and cry and go to the capitol and
smear [ __ ] on the wall and take over our
government and hang government officials
that we have elected to represent us
and everyone's worried about the
violence well
there's probably going to be violence
it seems that way they're hell-bent on
it on the dark web they're hell-bent on
it in the comments they want civil war
hell it's trending on twitter this
morning civil war
civil war
well if january 6 was any indication of
how their operations go in a civil war
well
we got a pretty damn good chance with
those folks
and i don't think
that real american people the real
american people are gonna put up with
anyone
causing violence in the name of donald
trump because he stole a bunch of [ __ ]
and he committed crimes give me a
[ __ ] break
i can only imagine when we start these
january 6th select hearings in september
how the tides to turn even more
we're going to turn this tide on them
jesus christ gasoline prices are
dropping
there's no sign of an actual recession
inflation is going in the opposite
direction
unemployment is going in the direction
that we want it as an economy as a
working people
and yeah we need a lot more help
that's what the inflation reduction act
is supposed to do is supposed to relieve
a lot of your your highest cost which
health care is one of the highest cost
so we could use some relief in health
care yeah sure we could do that but if
you think you're gonna elect a bunch of
fascists and they're gonna fix health
care [ __ ] they're still running on on
taking away your goddamn health care
they want to take it away [ __ ] they
voted against it they want your insulin
to be as expensive as it possibly can be
they really want to dig in
you know get those get those insulin
manufacturers and the drug manufacturers
some goddamn money [ __ ]
they need to you know get some campaign
contributions by god there needs to be
some profit for insulin [ __ ]
they vote against holding corporations
specifically oil companies accountable
for gouging of gasoline prices they
don't want babies to get baby for me
they just like to [ __ ] about it
they absolutely don't want veterans to
have health care [ __ ] no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
those people aren't any good to us
anymore they have cancer and they can't
be soldiers so [ __ ] them that is how
they feel
that is what they're doing that is the
message they're sending to you folks
fish bumping on the floor ted cruz
another piece of [ __ ] in texas
another reason why you should go to the
ballot and show your support for beto
not only that engage in your democracy
get people to the polls register people
make sure who they're voting for and
when they're voting and make sure they
do not abstain that is one thing we have
to make sure folks everyone who's
registered to vote goes and [ __ ]
votes
the turnout will will make democracy
ring
that's what they're [ __ ] terrified of
they're terrified of it and frankly
trump is doing nothing and his
supporters like carrie lake and others
are doing nothing but suppress their own
vote because these people don't even
trust the voting system anymore
they don't even want to vote because
they think it's so voting is corrupt why
would you want to vote that's corrupt
these [ __ ] boneheads are almost there
they're i'm serious they're they're only
within a few election cycles of saying
oh
voting is corrupt
that voting isn't democracy voting's
corrupt we don't want to vote we want to
put one person in charge and have them
tell us what we're supposed to do
i'm not kidding you
these people lost their [ __ ] minds
i mean you've seen that
the nonsense that they've put on about
this fbi raid
down at mar-a-lago
there's more to that story i hope that
we we see
more and more as it rolls out there's an
informant oh hmm who could have guessed
you know
you know i've been surmising since it
happened that there was probably a fbi
implant into the national archives
that's what i said i said there was
probably an implant into the national
archives when they went and got those
first 15 boxes there was probably fbi
agents dressed up for people who worked
at the national archives
and they were operating they were
operating on the information of an
informant inside mar-a-lago now who that
is who knows a lot of people are
speculating a lot of different things
i think it's inside mar-a-lago some are
saying mark meadows i think that's
[ __ ]
but there's evidence there that that
could be who the informant is because
the attorneys of donald trump have have
told him to stop contacting mark meadows
the thing i want to know here's the
thing i want to know
who's been wearing a wire around this
[ __ ]
i'm dead serious
i'm not [ __ ] you
you're my favorite turd i would not [ __ ]
you
i want to know who's been wearing a wire
around the son of a [ __ ]
you know there's someone wearing a
[ __ ] wire
you know this this informant
or whoever's working undercover around
this [ __ ] is wearing a goddamn wire
maybe that's how they know who what he
sold to who
that's right i think he [ __ ] sold
some [ __ ] that was ours out of the white
house classified information there ain't
no way he gave that [ __ ] away from free
are you [ __ ] kidding me
if he gave away classified information
to a third party no [ __ ] way
no way
did he not sell that [ __ ] no way
he a hundred percent would not give away
classified information that was high
valued and not get top dollar for that
[ __ ] no way not that broke son
of a [ __ ]
no way he's continuing to beg for money
from his broke ass supporters
they're probably giving every [ __ ]
last dollar they can every month
his
his money laundering machine in new york
is about to get
busted up with a goddamn hammer from
tish james after he bled the fifth as if
bleeding the fifth is something it's a
civil trial dude it's a civil trial it's
sybil
so the purpose is to find out how much
money you owe the state
it ain't about whether you committed
crimes or not but he pled the fifth
and pleading the fifth in a civil trial
like that is gonna be held against him
that he's not cooperating
that he's holding back information that
they're hiding [ __ ]
and my guess is tis james already has
the [ __ ] information that they're
trying to hide
whoops
uh-oh
what a dumb [ __ ]
but we need to come after these son of a
[ __ ]
we need to lean into democracy just like
bet o'rourke did last night in texas at
that rally
and you watched as that audience
responded immediately
immediately to the righteous anger a
better aurorak and that guy laughing
about 19 children
being slaughtered
he was describing
19 children being slaughtered and what
he wants to do to get those weapons off
the street so that doesn't happen again
and here this [ __ ] trumped-up white
dude this old trumped-up white dude in
the corner holding a greg abbott sign in
support of beto's opponent opponent
is laughing
out loud
loud enough for them to hear because i'm
sure that's what happens at these
[ __ ] rallies is these [ __ ] idiots
are trying to be as loud as they
possibly can to try to knock beto off
his game
well that didn't [ __ ] work did it
didn't turn out very well [ __ ] around
and find out you pieces of [ __ ]
because this is the attitude that we
need
to win we need to stop this [ __ ]
white lot you know like loving these
people and dancing around the truth and
both sides and [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here we need to take
it right to him take the gloves off
and we need to win our democracy back
it's time
it's time pro-democracy people finally
step up the majority of people say
enough is enough of this [ __ ] we're not
gonna put up with it just like in kansas
when the legislator wanted to take
women's rights and women in kansas said
uh no [ __ ] you do not get to take our
rights i do i don't think so
it's time we do that all across the
spectrum everywhere all the way down to
the goddamn dog catcher if you get a
whiff just a stench of trump on any
candidate anywhere go vote for their
opponent please would you do that please
just a just a [ __ ] whiff
of trump just a whiff
you're out [ __ ]
one strike and you're out that's enough
of this [ __ ]
and you can do it you can do it
everywhere
it doesn't matter where you're at you
can engage in your democracy not just
going and voting you can register people
you can talk to your community members
that's what bet o'rourke's doing
that's exactly what he's doing he's not
holding big huge rallies in auditoriums
he and and stadiums he absolutely could
probably be doing that but he's not he's
going these to these communities
and he's talking to the community
members
and that is the effect that it's having
and you can do the same exact thing you
can do the same exact thing
you do not need permission from anyone
to start talking to your community
members your family your friends the
people in the pta your fellow church
members
hell if you want some talking points
just go look at beto o'rourke's twitter
page or his instagram page he'll give
you plenty of reasons and plenty of ways
to talk to people about your community
and your democracy
because his message isn't his message
down in texas is a message of community
that's what it's about
i mean you just you just take the word
texas out and put your community name in
and bam
you don't think your community members
want to feel safe from from weapons of
war you don't think your community
members want health care especially
mental health care in the state that our
country's in they want access to it
you don't think that your community
members want a decent [ __ ] wage
they don't want to go bankrupt over a
goddamn medical bill
they want children to start school at
three instead of five these are
important issues folks
but we gotta lean into democracy to get
them taken care of we can't just hope
and wish and pray
that the right people win and those
policies will [ __ ] out automatically no
you have to do the work democracy is
difficult
it's hard democracy is not easy that's
why liberal democracy and liberals are
not weak they're strong they're the ones
who lean in they do the [ __ ] work
they get the [ __ ] done no matter what
anyone says no matter what the challenge
is no matter what the obstacles liberals
do the [ __ ] work authoritarians
fascist conservatives
they don't do any work
their job is to not do work their job is
to work to obstruct
and to tear down our democracy and
that's easy that's easy to pick one
[ __ ] and believe everything they
say no matter what they say no matter
what donald trump says i believe it oh
hell yeah hell yeah i believe that makes
it easier on me i don't actually have to
think all i got to do is listen what his
dumb ass says and i believe it ha ha
this is fantastic it's real easy i don't
even have to i don't have to think
sometimes i mean it's it's so it's so so
great i just watch fox news oh am
newsmax they tell me what to say what
thing and boom i think it and then i say
it
it's not that it's not that difficult to
be in a [ __ ] authoritarian to be a
goddamn fascist
you don't have to use much brain power
to do that
but liberal democracy is hard
it's hard
and you have to engage in and a great
way to engage in it is to watch here
every single weekday monday through
friday we air two hours live youtube
twitter and twitch and simon casting
from the midas touch facebook page if
you want to give us support here on our
channel on the tony michaels podcast go
to
thetonymichaels.com at the very top of
the the website there's a link there's
also some great merch if you want guys
want to support that way as well but if
you want to support our show we would
much appreciate it
go to
thetonymichaels.com and spread the love
there
folks i am so excited to have you
i'm glad that all the new listeners are
keeping tuning in they're not stopping
we're growing tell your family tell your
friends where to come
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page this is the
tony michaels podcast don't go anywhere
we got a lot of [ __ ] to get through on
twitter we're gonna surf the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends as soon as
we come back don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live love and blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around to the break
i see we have a lot of sparklers
in the chat today thanks for joining us
hal sparks supporters there's a lot of
crossover with me and hal
i love the sparklers having the
sparklers here with us on the tony
michaels podcast when hal isn't
broadcasting you know a lot of people
have said that hal and in our show
overlap a little bit here's the great
news here's the great news i record my
show i'm not exactly sure where hal i
think he's on youtube and twitch and
some things but we record our show here
at the tony michaels podcast so you can
go to youtube you can follow every
single episode episode even if you miss
it you can watch it every single weekday
you can watch it live noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
or twitch or simulcasting from the mind
as touch facebook page but if you miss
it it's okay
because you can get it right here on the
youtube channel as soon as we're done
you can replay that thing a hundred
times if you want and you can go get
caught up on all the episodes this is
episode 202 holy [ __ ]
you can also download every single
episode on apple's spotify google all of
your favorite directories
make sure to leave us a great review
while you're there downloading and
download every episode even if you watch
it download it for me why not give us
some support there and again if you want
to give us support here on the tony
michaels podcast because we're here
every day
every weekday working hard to try to
bring you the news and bring it to you
in a way that has cathartic relief but
also gives you the ability to go out
into your community and say look
those republicans [ __ ] them [ __ ] em [ __ ]
em [ __ ] em so stay tuned give us support
go to thetonymichaels.com
and give us some support today's
thursday you guys know that you know
what happens on thursday we put out the
bonehead of the week poll so make sure
to subscribe here on youtube cause that
poll comes on youtube but it also goes
over on twitter follow us on twitter at
the tony michael at tony michael's pod
excuse me that tony michael spot you can
follow me at the tony michaels and you
can follow my co-host and executive
producer gabe sanchez at i am gabe
sanchez on twitter as well
keep up with all the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends we're always over
there tweeting gabe probably tweets more
than i do
he probably tweets one i would say he
tweets more than i do i mean i tweet i
tweet often
and i retweet things that i see because
i want to show them to you on the show
there's so many
great things that you guys need to see
to keep up with what's going on
that way you know what these
chuckleheads are saying
it's so important to know what the
republicans are saying i mean we're not
going to sit here and bash pro-democracy
people that's not what the [ __ ] we do on
this show we're not both sides and [ __ ]
that's a bunch of [ __ ] if anyone's
out there saying both sides of this both
sides that they're the same they're
saying [ __ ] you they are not the same
not even [ __ ] close
and we show you how they're not the same
i pointed out i put a big amplifier on
it you know shine a spotlight on it so
you know that way when someone says that
nonsense you can tell them to [ __ ] off
just like beto did you think that shit's
funny i don't think it's funny
[ __ ]
and there's a lot of [ __ ] that's funny
on twitter today but there's a lot of
[ __ ] that ain't funny and i want to get
to that clip
a betto
absolutely dunking that piece of [ __ ] in
the trash
so let's surf the tweety tweets and
trendy trends folks it's time for the
shitless roundup
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the [ __ ]
list roundup
welcome back to the show we're going to
surf the tweet tweets twinning trends
but tim here says dark sparklers is that
the sparklers that come over and watch
our show or the dark sparklers ooh i
like that i like the sound of that
like i'm dark hal or something i don't
know
ow boy i love having everyone here the
entire audience rather your sparklers or
not the midas mighty's here too and i
think the midas money and the sparklers
have a lot of crossover as well this
pro-democracy community that we're
creating folks is really kicking ass and
taking names
kicking ass and taking names
and there's no better evidence than the
video that was put out by better or
campaign holy [ __ ] [ __ ] he eats this
guy's lunch
rolls him up up and smokes him like a
joint
i know i bet i bet beto smokes he he's
always playing music with willie nelson
no waiting no way he did not smoke right
he rolled this guy up like a [ __ ]
joint and smoked his ass smoked him
you saw it
i'll tell you so but we're gonna watch
it we're gonna watch it again i can't
stop watching this [ __ ] thing
i probably watch this damn video at
least at least 50 times this morning
how i watched it several times last
night
but here's the video better work let's
make it bigger
let's go to the part the good part here
it's about right here
so what beto is doing in this first 41
seconds and before that he's describing
the uvalde shooting
where 19 children and two teachers were
slaughtered cut up by a weapon of war
and i guess at these these uh these
events that beto has these community
events that he has
there's usually a lot of hecklers at
these events we we watched a video i
don't know
it was last week where some kind of
pastor showed up with the [ __ ]
firearm thought he was too cool and
tough
needs his ass kicked is what he needs
people like that need their [ __ ]
asses kicked well bet o'rourke puts this
guy in his
spot this guy's standing in the back of
the room laughing out loud as if it's
funny that 19 children and two teachers
were slaughtered
by a weapon of war and that that this 18
year old
with mental health problems had the
ability to go with the credit card and
purchase
on credit to two weapons of war in 1700
rounds
to go slaughter children at an
elementary school and that's what he did
and this guy's in the back of the room
thinking that shit's [ __ ] funny
well i don't think i don't think better
supporters think that shit's funny and
he doesn't either watch how he responded
500 feet and knock him down dead
up against kids at five feet it may be
funny to you [ __ ] but it's not
funny to me
[Applause]
i want to point out something in this
video right here
this gentleman that stood up
with the cap on here seems like he's
uh and i can't tell exactly what the hat
says but he looks like an older
gentleman
looks like he's probably
been in battle before
he knows exactly what the [ __ ] that was
talking about
he knows exactly what the [ __ ] better
was talking about when he's describing
what he's describing
and the reason why these people are
[ __ ] cheering is because they're sick
and tired of these [ __ ] politicians
putting up with this [ __ ] where
these [ __ ] are coming and
laughing at stuff like 19 children being
slaughtered they're
they're they are sick of that [ __ ]
they're just tired of it they don't want
any more of the [ __ ]
and bet o'rourke made this made this guy
look like a [ __ ] fool and this man
here is clapping his ass off
because these people want us to stand up
for them
that's what they want
they want us to fight for them and beto
knows it and betto's fighting for his
community john
fetterman fighting for his community tim
ryan fighting for his community warnock
fighting for his community kelly in
arizona fighting for a community stacey
abrams fighting for her community
and that's the language that we have to
use here folks and we gotta lean into
this democracy stuff we gotta lean way
the [ __ ] in
it's time our country come back to its
original values
which is [ __ ] decency and empathy and
the progress of equality and equity for
[ __ ] sake
let's watch again i want to watch it
again i'm going to watch it again that's
right i'm gonna watch it again i don't
give a [ __ ]
we're gonna watch it several times let's
watch it a soldier's helmet at 500 feet
and knock him down dead
up against kids at five feet it may be
fun to you [ __ ] but it's not
funny to me okay
[Applause]
the best part about this is there's
another version of this video that's a
little longer and better doesn't doesn't
miss a beat [ __ ] doesn't miss
beat
keeps going
keeps talking to his community telling
his community members what the [ __ ] he's
gonna do about
the laws that greg abbott has [ __ ]
wrought on texas that allowed that 18
year old to buy weapons of war and
slaughter those children
better work is talking about what the
[ __ ] he plans on doing for his community
texas
when he becomes governor as greg abbott
does nothing [ __ ] nothing but lie
that lying sack of [ __ ] [ __ ]
better roar takes it right to him let's
watch it one more time i just i can't i
can't stop watching it helmet at 500
feet and knock him down dead up against
kids at five feet it may be funny to you
[ __ ] but it's not funny to me
okay
[Applause]
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em beto you got it
right [ __ ] em that's what i tweeted [ __ ]
em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em not for that
[ __ ] uh olivia says here damn [ __ ]
right
let's bring this up here
olivia responded i retweeted hers this
morning she said
damn [ __ ] right the people texas
deserve a governor he's passionate about
protecting our lives and that's exactly
what better roar will do
donate to his campaign below she's got
the link there
if you're not following olivia also by
the way you are missing out
she's the one that raised over two
million dollars because matt gantz is a
[ __ ] dummy
that's the [ __ ] we need
it's the tide's turning folks the tide's
turning
it is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the tide's
turning
uh let's see here i had some more video
i want to show oh
gabe sanchez
gabe sanchez
yeah
he may or may not have uh made a shirt
that defunds marjorie taylor green go
check out
gabe's
i don't know where the hell he's at
where the hell is our co-host where the
hell is he
i don't even notice he's gone yeah let's
let's message where
the hell are you
are you guys wondering where the hell
gabe's at oh breaking news uh what's
going on what's going on
um
looks like um
on the fbi attack in cincinnati okay
well let's see if we can go find this
does someone have a link
you can uh send me a link robin if you
got a link you can send it to me
oh looks okay
yeah he's he's he must be working on
something gabe gabe said he'll be here
in about 15 minutes he's running late
folks should we give him [ __ ] because
he's running late i think we should
let's see let's see what this is
um looks like some breaking news here
maybe
spiro agnew's ghost has this it says
breaking uh federal investigators had
previously seized national security
documents from trump's florida estate in
june 2020 with a grand jury subpoena so
look here we are here we are they are
they are they are taking documents all
the way back in june
the reason why the fbi went in is
because this motherfucker's hiding [ __ ]
or he done sold it like i said
or he done sold it he's committing
crimes [ __ ]
yeah of course the fbi's gonna go knock
down his door when you keep climbing and
[ __ ] jesus christ this is not
the the dude's business in new york city
the most criminal president we have ever
put in the white house has a business
that he has ran in new york city for
[ __ ] decades
and that [ __ ] that business is
under criminal indictment along with the
cfo
this is not a surprise why the [ __ ] are
these trump supporters so goddamn
surprised i can't [ __ ] figure it out
i really can't
i can't figure out why they're so
goddamn surprised that the fbi is
kicking down their [ __ ] door they're
being deposed at every [ __ ] every
[ __ ] day they're being deposed
there's more criminal investigations
popping up all the [ __ ] time they
can't stop
and the reason why is their [ __ ]
criminals
how don't these [ __ ] see it
jesus [ __ ] i guess it's because the
the tv television tube told them so well
fox news says they're not criminal oh a
ancestor great
uh newsmax says they're being they're
being oppressed
you [ __ ] idiots a bunch of dumbasses
just like this [ __ ] idiot marjorie
taylor green do you see what she tweeted
yesterday
she tweeted a screenshot look at this
a [ __ ] screenshot of her calling
scott perry's phone
i'm not [ __ ] you
she she was calling
scott perry's phone
and it goes to voicemail she says
i don't know what the [ __ ] she means
here really honestly i don't get this i
don't understand what she's trying to
say
marjorie taylor green's dumb ass tweets
i just tried calling the fbi to ask them
why they confiscated the sending members
of congress's personal cell phone why
would you want to know that are you next
that's what i that's what i wrote i
wrote are you next
and then she put it rang twice and went
to voicemail of course it rang twice and
went to voicemail you dummy
they got the phone he said he got the
phone
what a [ __ ] bonus what is i don't
even know what the hell she's trying to
prove here is she trying to prove that
scott perry's phone was was seized by
the fbi
is that what she's trying to prove and
that that that it is perfectly legal for
the fbi to confiscate sitting members of
congress's personal cell phone if they
committed crime on it especially if they
committed crime
with i don't know someone like john
eastman and they got his cell phone
because i told you yesterday that's what
the [ __ ] this is
that's going on here the reason why
the fbi took [ __ ] scott perry's phone
is because scott perry was texting
[ __ ] john eastman more than likely
and the reason why is because they were
both involved in this [ __ ] cheeto
dust kangaroo coup these fake electors
this scheme that they were trying to
overturn our vote they were trying to
[ __ ] usurp democracy and take our
government away from us
that we elected
not just the [ __ ] federal government
the [ __ ] state governments who
certified the goddamn boat
they're trying to overturn those [ __ ]
governments too those democracies this
is all [ __ ] [ __ ] nonsense
and that's why they [ __ ] took scott
perry's phone is because they want to
see the two-way conversations of scott
perry because they can only see one side
of the conversation for scott perry on
john eastman's phone think about it if
you have your cell phone right you're
texting some dumb ass and that dumb ass
is telling you about conversation that
they had with some other dumbass you can
only see one side of that conversation
so the only way to see the [ __ ]
conversation between the other dumbasses
is to take that dumbass's phone the
dumbass being scott perry well really
being all of them let's be frank
what's that
let's not get too out of tort they're
all [ __ ] dumb asses here marjorie
taylor green and the rest of them they
all thought they were going to get away
with this because they thought they were
actually going to overturn the
government donald trump was going to be
crowned king and if the fbi came after
him they just pardoned him just pardon
them because we know scott perry was
looking for a [ __ ] pardon we know
marjory taylor green was inquiring about
[ __ ] pardons
matt cats and on and on he goes
so they thought he was just going to
take over the government be dictator be
king and if the fbi came after them i'll
[ __ ]
you can't take their phone i pardoned
them that's what they thought
[ __ ] boneheads
what a [ __ ] idiot i'm gonna tell her
here too her [ __ ] tweet sucks your
tweet sucks
it's horrible what a shitty tweet
i don't even know what it really means
to be honest with you
i really don't
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is
supposed to mean
she called the fbi but here she's
calling scott perry
i don't know if she called scott perry's
phone thinking the fbi would pick it up
which actually honestly she's so [ __ ]
dumb
the fbi could have picked up this call
can you imagine that
and pick up the call and they just act
like they're scott perry
yeah scott
it's scott
yeah okay yeah well you know
i i think they i think they want to get
to the crimes that we committed on
january 6 marge
those crimes that we committed she'd be
like oh yeah wow they're really after us
aren't they they sure are wink
this is scott
you think that's how he answers his
phone or he's like he's some kind of
pompous ass he's like this is
representative scott perry you're you're
you're you're trumped up you're trumped
up make america again for america first
congressman some [ __ ] like that what do
you think you think it's just oh this is
scott this gut
i don't know oh my god
i just i i gotta show you this
joe has brought back becky sue becky's
shoes back folks
becky sue is back and she's vivid she's
vivid y'all
let's listen to becky sue
hey y'all it's me becky sue here doing
my daily video vlog update for y'all so
update i'm pissed okay i'm mad as hell i
am
vivid right now okay y'all know how they
stormed into our president's house in
florida kicked in the doors and went
through melania's panty drawers and
everything well
today
they made him sit in new york city
for a death is just
for a dis disposition
they made him sit and asked him all
these mean questions and it gets worse
okay
then they made him take the fifth
commandment now only the fifth
commandment they made him take all the
commandments first second third fourth
and
fifth i know about y'all but i thought
this was america i thought we were
founded on freedom
the freedom of of speech
and the freedom the freedom to to be
christian
and ain't the freedom of
guns
and the freedom
to take some classified documents from
the white house to your golf course in
florida if you are the president of the
united states of america
well
i guess i was wrong
if they can come for donald j trump they
can come from me
and they can come for you
well
that's all for today
okay stay safe out there y'all bye
oh becky sue one of my one of my
favorite characters of satire uh go
follow jojo from jurors
and and make sure to follow the becky
sue videos they are fantastic you guys
know the truckers convoy the commercial
that we ran um in the first part of the
show that was actually written that was
written by jojo from jurors and
she she plays tammy in that video and i
play bob and then gabe narrates it and
gabe cut it together so that was a
collaborative effort that uh truckers
convoy
but um some of it was inspired by becky
sue and her relatives the character
becky sue so go follow joe
uh becky sue is back
so um
one of the greatest satire characters
that i've come across i love becky sue
becky sue has actually been on our show
before um she's been on our show so go
go give joe some love on becky sue she
tricks a lot of people with becky sue
like when you first see becky sue you
think that's a real [ __ ] trump
supporter
like a real one did you guys think it
was really a trump supporter
some bonehead
she does a great job with that character
and that character oh boy
oh boy
okay well here's a bonehead
so yesterday we found out there's an
informant right
well let me get my screen going here
right
we find out there's an informant
yesterday the fbi has an informant and i
asked for wrong answers only
but this here
this is a video
okay of newsmax now this is really
[ __ ] the reason and i i i embedded
their video news max i would hardly ever
embed newsmax video [ __ ] no
but i thought it was super important to
embed their video yesterday here's why
the reason why it's so important to
embed
news max's video on the fbi informants
because these [ __ ] are the ones
who were telling us that it was all
[ __ ] you know they're still telling
us oh they're they planted evidence and
blah blah blah and it's all a [ __ ]
it's all witch hunt and they're trying
to take down donald trump you know all
this nonsense
listen to how newsmax frames it up as
soon
as soon
as the the news drops of the informant
inside mar-a-lago watch
breaking news right now for you a
bombshell report brand new from newsweek
coming out just this afternoon
saying that an informant told the fbi
exactly what documents former president
trump was hiding and where they were
located at mar-a-lago
uh-oh
uh-oh even newsmax has to admit
yep he [ __ ] up there's an informant
uh-oh
rat road that's a great piece of tape
folks that's a great piece of tape i'll
show that to your relatives to your
friends you know i you know i say that
all the time
give it to him show it to him
super important
do not let up on this stuff
well let's see
what else the video do we got here let's
go to the um
to the tweety tweets let's go to the
trends here
um we have uh uh
yeah beto is still trending there's a
video i want to show you in this thread
i thought i retweeted it but i must have
not grabbed it um there's a video of
beto signing here we go this is it um
this is i was talking earlier about beto
signing a make america great again hat
here it is
so i'm a republican but i genuinely
would like to know
what your plan if you were to become
governor
what is your plan to do about mental
health
we are 51st in the nation today in
mental health care access our largest
provider of mental health care services
is a county jail system because our
fellow texans who are uninsured all too
often go to the county jail as the only
place where they're guaranteed some
level of care 120 bucks to do that
imagine what we would spend it would be
a fraction of that to expand access to
mental health care to everyone who needs
it
now you notice this language again i
want you to focus in on
on what he's saying but more importantly
it is not about exactly what beto is
saying
right it's not the exact words in the
exact order
but he's using his voice in a way
because it's how he's saying it
it's how he's saying it
and that's the most important thing
is that beto is talking about community
and he's saying in a way that people are
listening
they're not bored with stats and and all
this nonsense he didn't he didn't give
you any he didn't give you any stats
he just told you the truth hey there's a
shitload of people going to county jails
getting mental health care because they
can't [ __ ] go anywhere else because
we don't have mental health care in our
communities and people need it in our
communities
that's what he said it's how he's saying
it listen i mentioned earlier expanding
medicaid that 10 billion dollars that
would come in not once every single year
to this day we use it for primary care
we use it for obstetrics we use it for
mental health making sure that we have
more psychiatrists psychologists
therapists and social workers right here
in this community right here in this
community
you got it you follow it you see
so expanding mental health care and
taking us from 51st in the nation to
first if i have anything to do about
with it is not only the right thing to
do it'll make us so much more stronger
economically it'll improve the lives of
every single one of us and again it will
reduce pressure on our property
here's the part where the person who
asked him the question
uh with the make america great again hat
comes in to approach him to thank him
for his answer to their question
there's some common ground somewhere
right
and there you have it there you have it
oh how good does that feel how good does
that feel for better o'rourke to sign a
make america great again hat that person
took off their trump hat
and had better o'rourke signed it holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] the tide the tide is
turning folks i know it doesn't feel
like it i know it feels like now there's
we're never gonna make it this is this
is hopeless no it's not no it is not
and we can lean into this and we can
help candidates like betto who was who
was giving the right [ __ ] message
and saying it the right way
because it's not just about what he's
saying it's how he's saying it and
that's why this trump supporter wanted
so badly for beto to sign their trump
hat
with a sticker on it that says i voted
what kind of message does this send
they should be terrified folks and they
better be
these [ __ ] nazis running these
nuremberg rallies in texas
letting them get away with their
outright fascism calling themselves
domestic terrorist
as if it's some kind of [ __ ] joke
well it ain't funny [ __ ] and i
don't find it very [ __ ] funny
to take words at a better aurora's mouth
so get behind your community
do the thing that democracies do
and engage in your ballot have that
strategic outrage that righteous anger
and let's kick their [ __ ] asses
in this midterm let's kick their [ __ ]
asses in this midterm it is time
it is time and thank you to beto
o'rourke
for being a champion of communities
we need more of it i think there's some
more better um footage here
um i want to show the the video where
um beto actually
that's the wrong one there's another
there's another clip of this beto
um
and i think it's this one here
uh adam parkamenko uh retweeted there's
two videos it's the same video but one's
longer than the other
and this is the one put out by better
media
the other one was a travis acres with i
think and i think travis shot this video
i believe is what what happened but beto
got there metal media got their hands on
an extended version uh anna parkaminko
says it may be funny to you [ __ ]
but it's not funny to me quoting quoting
beto here but uh let's watch this one
more time
but there's an extended part of this
sorry about the sound there's an
extended part of this
um and you can watch as the crowd calms
down beto doesn't skip a beat watch
up against kids at five feet it may be
funny to you [ __ ] but it's not
funny to me okay
[Applause]
they're gonna make sure
[Music]
they're gonna make sure
we're going to make sure
that our kids who are starting their
school year right now
that they don't have to worry
about somebody walking into their school
with a weapon like this that we take
common sense steps we find the common
ground democrats and republicans gun
owners non-gun owners
and there it is speaking more about
community uh than any other candidate
out there and beto is giving paving the
way showing you exactly the the
what what you should do on a on a
political campaign especially right now
in our country because people are
[ __ ] sick of this [ __ ]
they're absolutely sick
and tired of the nonsense
and beto is too he's not putting up with
that [ __ ] hell no got no [ __ ] to give
so let's go back to the uh
let's go back to the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends here
uh let's see
betto's trending what else do we have we
had some other stuff um
cincinnati fbi someone was telling me
about the fbi in cincinnati cincinnati
fbi threatened now armed suspect uh
flees scene according
now to the fbi cincinnati division an
armed suspect attempted to break into
the visitor screening facility about 9
a.m on thursday oh here we go here's
some dem speaking of domestic terrorists
well son of a [ __ ]
speaking of domestic terrorists
of course of course there's a bunch of
domestic terrorists trying to break into
the cincinnati fbi um here's here's
charlie kirk i guess responding to it
live on some trader tv news network uh
let's let's listen to what dumb buck has
here to say
there's a little bit of a trepidation
that the
mockingbird media doesn't really know
what to make of this they're not really
sure how to cover it there is a single
angle though they're going to be
continually using which is
denouncing threats to law enforcement as
if that's really what's going on here
director of the fbi had strong words
wednesday for supporters of former
president donald trump who have been
using you know what's funny he calls it
the mockingbird media and he's talking
about me
and he's talking about people like me
[ __ ] charlie kirk here this piece of
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] nazi yeah you're a [ __ ]
nazi charlie you [ __ ] had a teenage
rally down in florida invited the the
teenage sex trafficker matt gatz and
then you had a bunch of [ __ ] nazis
with flags outside your your [ __ ]
little your little
whatever the hell it was your nazi rally
you piece of [ __ ] but here he's calling
us the mockingbird media gabe he's
calling us the mockingbird media and
he's reading off a script he can't even
wait do we have a script here i don't
have no no we are all completely off the
cuff one hundred percent improv our
writers we fired they weren't good they
were they were [ __ ] there were a couple
that were fascist so they had to go
right right well they they kept writing
fast as [ __ ] trying to leak it into the
show so we fired their asses right here
charlie kirk's calling calling us the
mocking media the mockingbird media and
he can't even handle just talking into a
microphone that [ __ ] worthless piece
of [ __ ] let's listen let's listen i
think he says something about the
cincinnati fbi thing are you up on this
i haven't checked this out yet but but
let's listen yeah i'm uh i'm mostly up
to date right now so we can we can talk
about it after okay let's let's listen
using violent rhetoric in the wake of
his agency search
for trump's mar-a-lago home of trump's
mar-a-lago home he says that
threats against
federal agents and the justice
department are deplorable and dangerous
remember how many of those threats are
planted by the fbi themselves
oh jesus [ __ ] christ see this [ __ ]
again this false flag [ __ ] this is alex
jones nonsense is [ __ ] that it ain't
[ __ ] right-wingers they just had a
nazi rally a nuremberg rally and texas
gabe called cpac and deemed themselves
all they're all domestic terrorists
that's what it [ __ ] said on the
banner they thought it was hilarious by
the way yeah no they thought hey we're
gonna be tongue-in-cheek about this you
know the whole week we're going to talk
about how the fbi has been
uh politicized and has been uh
used for biden's administration right
like that is the thing that they're
going for but these people these
republicans these [ __ ] fascists will
take these talking points and will
regurgitate them
so many times that they've lost the
initial message of what it is and now
it's just anyone who is pro-democracy or
pro-justice following law and order
is the enemy
and that is it what happened today and
what is currently happening right now is
the result of all of their rhetoric the
gop right-wing media charlie kirk nick
fuentes donald trump all of these people
you mean you mean nazis is that what you
mean yeah yeah yeah oh yeah we could
just group them all together
this is the result of nazis and when
nazi supporters and sympathizers
look at this and say oh no no no no this
isn't fair and they go in with a [ __ ]
nail gun a rifle
uh what else is that what they had in
this sense and anything
i i'm reading right now there is mention
of a nail gun yeah fire is a suspect in
body armor fired a nail gun at law
enforcement inside the cincinnati fbi
building
um
shoots officers during armed standoff
and then he ran away into okay gabe all
i can think about right now when you're
saying that he tried to fire a nail gun
at a lot i think of happy gilmore when
they're on the construction site and
he's using the shoot the cans are you
[ __ ] serious these people absolutely
just
they can't quit like like literally if
we were gonna parry or satire this stuff
that might be something we would do
right right like you like like when i
initially read i was like oh armed
gunman he's got an assault rifle or he
has a handgun or something i mean he he
fired a nail gun and then when he uh and
then it sounds like he held up an ar-15
style rifle before fleeing in a vehicle
so he came with more than just a nail
gun but he decided to only start
shooting with the nail gun first why do
you think i mean what's going through
this motherfucker's head where he's got
an actual weapon and he's firing now you
think it's like he knows if he
brandishes this this ar-15 they might
they might take him out on site so so he
he gets his nail gun out to you know
kind of give him a thin belt threat here
of about no i mean like i guess i'll
nail you to the ground [ __ ]
like i i guess like anything in their
mind is like you know
it's a gun it's a gun
and now they're like they're gonna try
and ban nail guns
i don't know that could be that could be
it that could be the narrative let's
listen to what charlie has to say let's
what he has to puke up here in the
microphone we've said the entire time
remain peaceful we do not put up with
violent acts now there's a new report
that shows someone is so what he's
saying what he's admitting here gabe
here's what he's doing he's like we want
to incite violence and to make sure that
no one blames it on us
what we do is we actually say we don't
want that out loud
wink but we really want that
like we want our people you know we want
to do this but we we're going to sail
out to to never
never don't ever go to the cincinnati
fbi with a nail gun don't do that you
know and literally that's what they've
been saying
that's what that's what they're doing
[ __ ] the the idea that
i'm just like i'm still dumbfounded by
the fact that some guy this whole time
everyone's like hey they're coming after
our guns come and take it you know this
whole time they're talking about how the
reason that they need any sort of weapon
especially ar-15s is because they need
to defend themselves from the government
meanwhile they completely forget that
the government has i don't know [ __ ]
tanks bazookas uh [ __ ] drones they
could take you out like that if they
really wanted to you mean a nail gun is
no defense again as against a tank or a
drone yeah yeah come on come on that's
fake news that's fake news i'm just
saying right now they're looking at it
and they're saying oh they're coming
after our guns first it's the ar-15s and
it's the handguns next you don't know
it's gonna be the nail guns like that's
what that i guarantee the republicans
are definitely saying right now they're
coming after our nail guns
that is the ridiculous nature of all of
these [ __ ] cult followers of this
fascist
orange
wannabe mussolini like that is what it
is that's that's all that it is it is
the idea that a guy can go into
the [ __ ] fbi building
with a nail gun and say you know what
my odds look pretty good right now you
know this this gives me um um you know
flashbacks to january 6 when ashley
babbitt thought it was a good idea to
enter into a restricted area through a
broken window and thought you weren't
going to get smoked um i mean it just
it's the same thing like this guy
doesn't think he's going to have
ramifications if he walks up in the fbi
building with any kind of weaponry right
with body armor like what the [ __ ] are
you thinking like i don't even care if
you were carrying a [ __ ] water gun
like a water pistol yeah dude
people were in trouble i and
i'm surprised honestly that this person
wasn't [ __ ] shot on site i mean you
look at
you look at people he's proud he's
probably white well no of course that's
what i'm saying like if he was a person
of color or anyone who wasn't white
right you've got people who are in a
walmart with a toy handgun
right and they're shot to death right
like that is the that is the nature of
where we live in right now and because
this guy's white and he's able to walk
in and say hey i i deserve to
to you know he probably coming in there
and saying like you know what i deserve
to get all of the the stolen documents
that trump took from the white house and
from our government he's like i'm coming
in here [ __ ] rambo style two nail
guns thrown wheeled in and saying that
he's going to come in and save donald
trump from this investigation that's
already underway right and try to save
him save him from the the the idea that
trump is
is not already in trouble
um
but it just i'm just completely
dumbfounded that a guy would go in again
to the federal bureau of investigation
and say
this nail gun's gonna get me through i'm
gonna he's like he's like i'm gonna talk
to christopher wray and they're like
he's in dc and he's like this is good
enough guys right i'm gonna nail his ass
to the ground uh you know another thing
i want to point out here to the audience
watching uh on video now if you're
listening you're gonna want to go over
to youtube
and follow because you got to watch some
of this video that we show you
what is charlie kirk's ears getting
smaller or his face getting bigger and
his eyes not moving well what the [ __ ]
is happening i think what's happening
what the [ __ ] is this is when your head
begins to form in the shape of an
[ __ ]
your mouth
recedes to show more of the gums right
right
and so it actually becomes the
yeah yeah so you've got these little
like hemorrhoids up here and you've got
the little [ __ ] of his mouth right
but his face gets bigger his ears fall
behind i know man he's just can't even
see his ears at this point i know i'm
just like where do they go you know you
know i watched them he wears a hat just
to make his head look smaller so right
well i watched is that he thinks hats
make his head look smaller oh i've seen
him wear hats before and it does what is
he there does he cinch the hat down or
some [ __ ] no i think well from what i
remember he wears a little bit of a
bigger hat so what happens is proportion
wise when you look at that oh why he's
bit of an obstacle so it's like the
[ __ ] lady down at mar-a-lago that had
the big-ass foam hat that i showed
yesterday yeah yeah yeah the big huge
ass foam hat so he looks like a tiny
person underneath this really big right
the only difference though is by wearing
a bigger hat it looks like your head is
smaller maybe thus adding to do you have
a small brain maybe what we should do is
we should buy charlie one of those foam
hats and send it to him as a gift as a
gift as a gift you know make his make
his head look normal-sized i'm sure if
we ask rachel she might be able to give
us the address i i bet rachel could give
us the address she's been there she
might even sign it too you know what's
awesome about this whole charlie kirk
thing right being on screen on on monday
we're going to interview ben glebe a
comedian he's got the greatest [ __ ]
slam dunk on charlie kirk and abortion
and [ __ ] fetuses you've ever seen in
your goddamn life it is hilarious and in
this new comedy special that comes out
this weekend he talks about charlie kirk
but we asked him
we asked him about the that [ __ ]
interview
or the debate i guess it's called where
he slam dunks charlie in the trash and
he gives us some great insight on how we
got the videotape and how he didn't he
[ __ ] owned charlie not just in the
video but on getting the tape and
getting the footage it's fantastic you
gotta go watch that interview uh we
pre-recorded it but it's gonna come out
on monday uh so don't forget to to
subscribe to the tony michael's podcast
right here because it's super important
that you watch that interview because he
talks about charlie kirk and he talks
about that videotape but speaking of
charlie kirk and videotape let's finish
up what charlie has to say here about
inciting his own sort of violence
attacking the fbi building in cincinnati
interstate 171 north is shut down after
suspect drove towards waynesville ohio
unconfirmed reports say he is now firing
at police from a cornfield
now i'm sure this
wait it gets even deeper man it gets
deeper you know
i know i know let's listen let's finish
this up this will now be the main focus
even though we have said repeatedly to
remain peaceful and stay focused on
constructive things we wanted them to do
this we just don't want we just don't
want you to believe that we told them to
do this that's what he said guys we said
on tv that you know it's we're not gonna
do anything and this is all
uh this is all the right wing and this
is all
uh you know an insane amount of left
deep state woke-ism this is all them
this is not us guys we're telling them
to stay safe [ __ ]
no [ __ ] you not or not okay the people
on the right are you got [ __ ] people
on you know the the fox and friends and
sean hannity and [ __ ] uh jesse waters
and you've got the five they're all
talking
about how this was unfair and it was
unjust and it was unprecedented well
they're even they're even [ __ ]
floating this [ __ ] out there that
they're that oh all the evidence that's
gonna come out criminally against trump
it was all planted because they know
there's evidence right they know there's
that yeah that's a crime exactly the
only reason the only reason you ever
throw or float that idea out there is
when you fully expect
someone to say there's some pretty
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that you guys have over
here and it's evidence and then they
wanna they're trying to get up in front
of it and say
oh no no no guys if you hear anything
bad it's because they made it up right
it's fake news it's planted it's this
it's that they're anticipating them
finding something bad
because when they when i'm sure
when that call came in to trump you know
probably with his lawyers or his lawyers
around the phone with them or whatever
they're like we need you to tell us
right now
what the [ __ ] do you still have
and maybe he told the truth and maybe he
told him some asp like some you know uh
degree of what or the truth was and
they're like oh yep that's pretty [ __ ]
up okay uh we need to get a hold of this
and then
[ __ ]
uh his lawyer she goes on to onto fox
news or whatever and lies
now i'm not saying that she's gonna get
this barred but that's qualifications
for [ __ ] disbarment
well they're all [ __ ] liars i mean
that's for sure um
and you know
it's for it's ridiculous that we have to
continue to show this stuff but we got
to we got to show you this stuff and we
got to show you
look at this
macho man randy savage is trending i
don't mean to to jump subjects here
i think it's from an old clip right yeah
it's an old clip is the reason why it's
trending from arsenio hall's show in
1992 something about
yeah well arsenio i guess ask him
if he ever cries um let's let's watch
this clip i don't know i haven't seen
this yet let's see this okay your
your middle name is macho
but uh i'm wondering if you ever cry you
ever had a macho man ever crying oh yeah
really
it's okay for macho men to show every
emotion available right there you know
because i've cried a thousand times i'm
gonna cry some more but
i've soared with the eagles and i've
slithered with the snakes and i've been
everywhere in between and i'm gonna tell
you something right now there's one
guarantee in life and that there are no
guarantees yeah and
i understand this
nobody likes a quitter nobody said life
was easy so if you get knocked down take
the standing eight count get back up and
fight again and you're a macho maniac
ooh yeah
i like it
i like i like that i like that clip well
because i can guarantee you know just
from someone who goes through wrestling
which is not an easy sport i mean
there's a lot you know there's a lot
that goes into it there's a lot of
success and a lot of failure and there's
a lot of failure where you don't even
make it into the into you know the the
limelight right you know but you look at
this situation which is he you know
macho man randy savage probably dealt
with a lot of [ __ ] failure before he
became who he was you know right before
he i did like he was like oh this is my
persona this is what i am but the idea
that somebody was like oh yeah a macho
man randy savage the fact that he can
say oh yeah brother i cry all the time
you know like that
that just goes to show you that all
these [ __ ]
cry babies that say oh crying is for the
weak and crying is for women and crying
is for uh anyone who isn't a straight
man you know
just like i'll give you wrong dude well
they've been crying for the last several
days about this this this
right search warrant down in mar-a-lago
but this morning they're crying because
biden says uh inflation was zero percent
in july which he's not lying he's not
lying um representative i don't know
some nazi representative mike something
from somebody they can't
he's like biden says inflation was zero
percent in july inflation was eight and
a half percent in july no it wasn't dumb
[ __ ] that's from the last year you
stupid bad maybe maybe mike you should
go read the [ __ ] report see this is
the dumb [ __ ] that they do right this is
the dumb [ __ ] i will admit there are a
lot of representatives that i did not
know existed until this past week when
they were given a lot of dumb takes
whether it was about inflation it was
about uh the the the search that
happened at mar-a-lago like whatever it
was
there are people that are just making
themselves known and putting themselves
out there with the dumbest [ __ ] takes
i've ever seen which is like
it's easy to google you can google it
it's there you can even or you can go to
duckduckgo right okay fine you don't
want the big brother government track
and you go to duckduckgo and say you
know what was the inflation for july
2022 and i guarantee that you've
probably find some reports out there
that that would indicate what's going on
you know amy any amy vanderbilt says
wrong
now the eight and a half is how high
prices were up the last year from july
to july so the eight and a half is a
12-month period that's what they look at
is a year of inflation but in july the
prices rose zero percent is what biden's
trying to say so inflation
in july 2022
mike you dumb [ __ ] is zero
percent and she says it was accurate uh
also amy says i'm so sick of the
intentional misinformation and you and
your constituents should be too right
and thank you amy for your but i mean
can you doubt them even if they were
like intentionally spreading
misinformation or disinformation in this
matter like
i just can't imagine that they're very
good at numbers you know like they they
don't know the difference between seven
plus million votes well these people
were really convinced that elon musk was
gonna own twitter i mean they were
really convinced they were convinced
they were convinced that donald trump
was a good president they're still
convinced of that they some of them
still think he is the president yeah
some of them are hanging outside
mar-a-lago and wanted to get in and
everyone that was rich over there was
like
crazy ass um
ideas and speaking of [ __ ]
bone-headed people who want to be in our
government this mark is it mark muser is
that any say his name what's this
[ __ ] guy's name look at this guy oh
yeah this was another guy here's another
one you didn't know who the [ __ ] it is
yeah did not know who he was until i saw
this tweet yesterday and i was i had i
have something in the drafts but yeah
this is the
is it candidate for u.s senator
california constitution this guy claimed
he this guy's a [ __ ] attorney
yeah constitutional election law
attorney so you'd think that this guy i
don't know should be at least smart
enough to pass a bar test [ __ ]
i guess you know no offense to any
attorneys out there but it can't be that
hard to be a [ __ ] attorney and a
goddamn lawyer if this is the case if
this is the case because listen to what
this [ __ ] says he says imagine
imagine
gabe imagine the backlash
if while he was in office trump had
obama's home raided and aoc's phones
our aoc's phone seized listen to this
this is this is well then he goes on to
say are you tired of the double standard
no it's not a double standard that's the
point that's the point is
trump as the president did not have the
authority to direct the fbi to go raid
obama's home that is not how it works
that is not how any we are not an
authoritarian dictatorship that is not
how it [ __ ] works it's not even close
to how it works and it only makes me
wonder why anyone in california would
want this to be their [ __ ] candidate
for senate when he doesn't understand
what our government even is and this
person swears an oath to these
governments he's a [ __ ] attorney are
you kidding me he says he's a
constitutional attorney what
constitution on what [ __ ] planet well
i don't yeah the other thing here too is
neither of these two people obama wish
by the way obama went eight years
no affairs
no
no scandals other than a tan suit
uh
you know and i think also he
he had a his jacket off and rolled up
sleeves inside of
um inside of the oval office that was a
big scandal that was a big problem okay
but in eight years
nothing bad happened in regards to
scandals or controversies or you know
broken laws or fraud or scams or
whatever it might be
but the comparison that he's trying to
make here is saying oh obama and aoc
the difference here is very big trump
and scott perry
were in communication either together or
through another party they were dealing
with january 6th they were pro
overthrowing the government and
overturning the result of 2020 election
trump also
stole classified documents that we can't
even talk about what they are
that is the difference between aoc
who who by the way marjorie taylor green
who wants to defund the fbi
is is uh is obsessed with aoc defund the
police right that's her that's her
platform now right they want to defund
the police before the police can come
after them so at the end of the day the
comparison is
is just flat out wrong
because neither of these two people
obama and aoc have done anything illegal
they didn't try to overthrow the
government they didn't steal classified
documents they didn't try to overturn
the 2020 election that would be scott
perry and donald trump so
that again i didn't know who this guy
was until this tweet i saw last night
and i said well here we are with
one of the dumbest takes i've heard
today and there's been a lot of [ __ ]
that's happened over the last three days
we're you know four days in
and this [ __ ] isn't stopping now we've
got a guy who's you know trying to storm
the fbi building with a nail gun
thinking he's going to get these
documents back and get justice for the
poor poor treatment of donald trump
well everyone's telling me to hit the
tweet button
gabe tell these people i'm definitely
i'm not scared to tweet this [ __ ] not
even in the slightest you don't even get
a warning anymore but and i don't
they're like
twitter's like this guy is not he's not
[ __ ] around i'm also i'm also going
to tell him his [ __ ] tweet sucks
because it is ridiculous so there you go
i i'm not scared to tell these
[ __ ] where to go i'm not scared
i'm not scared i'm gonna give a [ __ ]
okay let's go back to um let's see
what's in them for you because um i'm
looking for some video here do you get
any good video this morning the the bed
oh man i i actually didn't look for much
video because i watched that thing like
1500 times this morning it's oh my god
yeah
dude he he in the moment he's like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] like the the
the the speed at which he threw that
[ __ ] out of his mouth
toward that guy
in the moment after talking about my
heart exactly right you know talking
about a serious subject which is the the
children and the teachers who were who
were slaughtered and then some guys
you know decides to laugh and he's like
you know what no we're you know we're
not gonna do we're not gonna do that
right
uh and i and i can't i can't imagine or
i can't imagine if i really wanted to
uh how the right will probably take this
and say hey that is not fair that's not
nice that's not politically correct
right the party that is willing to talk
about grabbing a woman by the [ __ ] and
saying you know denigrating racial slurs
homophobic transphobic slurs
um in in working on a platform that is
anti-american
it is funny to see these people
then complain about oh oh that just you
know what that wasn't that is not
the
the the etiquette of a candidate get the
[ __ ] out of here
you're gonna tell me that's not the
etiquette of a candidate but then you're
willing to let donald trump do all the
crazy and insane things that he said
they're out of their minds well here's a
video fifty shades of gray has it here
um
looks like this is a video from
cincinnati looks like some police cars
blowing up and someone else is setting
up a camera here
so maybe we'll get some more footage of
this but let's watch
now this seems to be local police here
that says federal protection so this is
the police force that protects the
building it looks like i'm not sure what
the hell is going on in this um 50
shades says an armed gunman tried to
break into the fbi building in
cincinnati making threats and then fled
the scene after shots were fired i-71
has been shut down to find him and
apparently he ended up in a cornfield it
sounds like
um
here let's see what kyle griffin has to
say here reuters
fbi says thursday morning an armed
suspect attempted to breach
a visitor screening facility at fbi
cincinnati so i would imagine when they
call it visitor screening facility
sounds like that's kind of like a lobby
area where people who want to go visit
the fbi have to go through security you
know to go through some checkpoints or
something right i'm not sure exactly
exactly what that what that means or
what it looks like but that that's what
it sounds like to me is that what it is
is that what you're getting out of this
the visitor screening facility like it's
kind of like a lobby area yeah it seems
like that's probably a place you go walk
through and they're like all right walk
to the metal detector and all the stuff
and then he's like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
i gotta i got a what i got a gun i got a
bunch of nails in my pocket i know i
mean
right do you get a hammer with that with
that nail gun there son are you doing
some roofing are you doing some framing
i i bet i bet he's never actually used
the nail gun for construction what do
you think okay let's see here
i would be curious you know what's
what's he buying you know did he go to
lowe's did he go to home depot did he go
to some
craigslist i don't know i guess
where did he get that nail gun we should
probably ask ben shapiro ben shapiro is
the expert on home improvement stores
you know yeah he goes and buys he goes
and buys great wood great hardwood
hardwoods hardwoods poplar is poplar is
very popular poplar is a very popular
wood
oh my god that's how long has that been
that's been over a year ago that was uh
that was yeah that was after the um the
bill was passed in georgia to say that
it was illegal to pass out water in line
yeah yeah yeah and home depot did
something and he was going to go show
him his democratic voting law he was
going to go show his vote or his support
to to home depot and i'm like you know
there's such thing as lowe's right like
what the [ __ ] do you think home depots
is the only goddamn warehouse uh home
improvement warehouse um so we're
following this uh news on the cincinnati
fbi um if anyone's got a link out there
and you want to dm it to us or if you
want to send it to or tag us or if you
can send it to our moderators speaking
of our moderators gabe let's give some
love to our moderators
robin and mj have been our moderators
for what a couple weeks now everything's
going swimmingly
probably longer than that i lose track
of time you know when you do two hours
every single day you lose track of what
[ __ ] month it is even i for sometimes
forget who i am i still think i'm in
july
you don't well you know when you're
building a bunker and working hard on a
deep state bunker sometimes you lose
track of a lot of things i'm sure have
you guys been using nail guns in the in
the bunker are just shovels
mainly just shovels we're dealing with a
lot of concrete so we're not really
pushing a lot of nail guns
i mean in the beginning we kind of set a
frame
but that's pretty much it i got you i
got you well uh i want to give a shout
out again to our moderator sir give a
give them some love in the chat because
they've been doing such a great job you
know that we don't kick trolls out like
just immediately we give them a shot we
give them a chance
but mj boy she can really trash them so
can ram and just smoke those trolls if
they need to be smoked so give our mods
some love go follow them
um on twitter so mods put your put your
handles there
in the in the chat so everyone can go
follow you on twitter uh get get mj and
robin some more followers on twitter
spread the love around and tell them how
much we love them we love having the
mods here so right i do want to actually
i do want to take a moment uh somebody
in the in the in the chat reminded me i
meant to say this the other day but
uh the other day i i misspoke so i want
to i want to give a quick correction
here so earlier in the week i said that
reinhardt judge reinhardt was uh
appointed by
uh former republican governor rick scott
however
the actual part of that is it's not that
he was appointed by reinhard but his
reinhardt's wife which is circuit judge
carolyn bell a former federal prosecutor
she was appointed to the bench by
governor rick scott so it wasn't
reinhardt but his wife so i misspoke i
just want to put that correction out
there yeah either way
regardless just having that correction
in there regardless it's still a
republican not a left-leaning issue so
just want to make the correction so
people know
um
but yes either way you look at it this
is not a left leaning woke uh attack on
trump this is you know people on the
right approved these measures these
warrants
um
and he's [ __ ] so i just wanted to make
that quick correction since i saw that
little reminder so i want to say thank
you
to uh see sibo cebu seabed i don't know
see boo
yeah okay i see i see they're on twitch
they're on twitch yeah they're on twitch
yeah so anyway i saw that thank you for
the reminder i meant to say it earlier
this week but then this week has been uh
as we all know this week has been a
non-stop [ __ ] show enhancement um so you
know if there is everything that we ever
like you know uh get wrong and it's
corrected later on and we don't make
sure to correct it make sure to let us
know
um so we don't spread disinformation out
there and we are not like the
republicans you know
uh we don't talk about how inflation for
the month of july was 8.5 percent right
we don't we don't spread fake stuff we
don't spread fake news or numbers no
[ __ ] here
you you got [ __ ] [ __ ] them um it
looks like air force one is trending
here gabe and i can only imagine why
oh that's why because everyone's losing
their [ __ ] that the president united
states went on vacation with his son wow
and his grandkids
and i'm sure i'm sure it's just
egregious that that the president
oh what is this what is it wait look at
that wait is that hunter biden that i
that is that hunter biden no that that
looks like that looks did did jared
kushner ivanka go on vacation with with
joe biden did they no no oh that's
probably this is probably an old picture
no no
this is the problem are they going on
vacation with the bidens
no i think i think jared kushner and
ivanka here this is a picture when they
went on vacation with donald trump and
the double standard in the [ __ ] and
i'm sure the fake news media the real
fake news media the traitor tv
will very interesting the double
standard the hypocrisy the
yeah it's ridiculous it's it's but it's
always it's it's been this way for a
long time steve ducey is now trending
douchey
douchey let's see what he has to say um
here's a clip from uh fox and friends
that's
he's talking about the raid here that
they're so upset about let's go again
and they got steve scalise here steve
scalise here we go there are a number of
people online and elsewhere who are
demonizing the fbi and
yeah
yeah they are yeah they are i wonder i
wonder how that could have happened i
wonder if like the the king dangling the
[ __ ] himself [ __ ] and cheap
himself put out a statement almost
immediately when the fbi was finished
rounding up all his garbage down there
at mar-a-lago i wonder if that's what
really started to incite it douchey
let's listen some republicans paul
gosseler a republican in your caucus
from arizona said we must does he say
gossler
he said gosler from arizona it's not
gossler where'd the l come from it's
goes-r right do i get that name wrong
you know what i think the l is silent
i mean i'm serious is there actually an
l in his [ __ ] name nope it's
g-o-s-a-r that's what i thought but he
just said gossler didn't he yeah i mean
unless i've been unless i've been saying
i could be
part in blankets right i mean wrong this
whole time i hope it's wrong i hope i've
been wrong that you know i like the same
thing chris asks for a wave chris n
asked for a wave so i'm giving you a
wave yeah yeah there you go
okay let's let's let's keep going here
let's destroy the fbi we must save
america i stand with donald trump
marjorie taylor green says defend the
fbi no no no no no no defend
yes we should
defend the fbi it is now it is now a
fact steve steve doucee reads about as
well as i do holy [ __ ] yeah one in the
actual [ __ ] i mean you know i i i read
these tweets out loud i'm not that great
at edit but man he's not good at it
either i should go apply for a job on
fox and friends can you imagine if
they'd give me a job on fox now i kind
of want to sell shirts that say defend
the fbi
oh my god let's let's finish here these
[ __ ] idiots i'm just curious whatever
happened to the republican party backing
the blue and in particular the 35
members of law enforcement federal law
enforcement at the fbi did he grow a
brain all of a sudden yeah yeah what he
did
i mean that's not that's a decent
question to ask steve i mean you know
you get the defund wrong and you get
right all right that's a decent but i
mean it's a call out it's like what
happened man back the blue baby you guys
were all about injecting that blue into
your veins you said you know these
[ __ ] colors don't you know don't
bleed these these blue [ __ ] flags
blue lives matter smurfs and then you're
gonna say
defund the fbi
yeah defund the police because they're
coming after them exactly they don't
want it around so that they can say
well we don't have the funding anymore
so we can't actually go after these
other people that were involved so uh
well anyway see you guys later you know
i actually surmised earlier because
marjorie taylor green tweeted the
screenshot of her trying to call scott
perry's phone
i
i don't know do you think in and i kind
of made a joke here on the show did you
play that clip earlier which clip the
clip where scott perry is on fox news
and they're asking him did he get his
phone back no i did not not yet i didn't
find that video it is amazing yeah find
that voice well here's the thing is that
um
i i
i kind of joked that the fbi should have
picked up like this is scott
this this is scott and just just start
talking to her like it was scott perry
she you know she wouldn't have known the
dish like your phone back yeah they gave
it back to me
like just pretend like you know they're
breaking up a little bit on the
connection right and she'd be like okay
look i needed to burn these documents
you know
something let's finish what uh what
steve scalise's answer here is
republicans used to back the blue now
they're saying [ __ ] the blue what's up
with that steve
yeah and frankly we're very strong in
supporters of law enforcement and it
concerns everybody if you see some
agents go rogue and if you see an agency
that doesn't have the right checks and
balances but that's not what they're
saying
that's not what they're saying that's
not what they said steve what they're
saying is they want to abolish and get
rid of the fbi not not get rid of the
rogue agents that's what they're saying
the reason why there's a psycho
a right-wing trumped-up psycho showing
up at an fbi office in cincinnati this
morning with a nail gun and an ar-15
trying to kill fbi agents is because of
your dumb ass both sides in this thing
oh well we're in support of law
enforcement well if you're so much in
law enforcement why the [ __ ] aren't you
aren't you doing an um ethics
investigations on your colleagues right
now who who want to take away
institutions of law enforcement in this
country if you really believe in
democracy and the role that our
government plays then you should have no
problem investigating like lou said
yesterday the day before i was like
look
if you want to investigate hunter biden
go right [ __ ] ahead dude go do it if
he's guilty [ __ ] charge him put him
in jail if someone does something
illegal they should do the time for the
crime that they did
this is not just a well we'll go after
this one person we'll go this other one
like i stand pretty firmly on the idea
that
i'm not going to play favorites between
parties if you do something wrong and
you do something legal then you should
be investigated and charged and so it
should go the same way for both parties
whether it's republicans or democrats if
somebody let's say
donald trump does something illegal then
he should be investigated
if hunter biden does something illegal
he should be investigated like the
projection of oh it's all hunter biden
it's all this [ __ ] laptop that's
causing the problems and then not
looking at their own their own selves
their own party for whatever pedophilia
or whatever it might be looking to go uh
maybe we're the problem
but they won't do that well steve
scalise is a hypocrite let's listen to
more of the hypocrisy i'm sure he's
going to puke it out of his his [ __ ]
hole here at the top this is coming
steve
who went right they were following a
search warrant we want to find that out
we want to find that out and that's why
we're asking these questions because oh
he's just tucker carlson asking fascist
questions that's all they're doing
that's all they're doing gabe is just
asking questions to incite violence
that's all they're doing right how can
but it's also based on nothing right the
claim they're making is that this was
some rogue team of 30 plus agents who
[ __ ] went in
all undercover and then broke into
donald trump safe
i don't think it really goes like that
and i don't think that stuff really
happens especially something that is so
[ __ ] so [ __ ] publicly known
and gets reported on
if you were to tell me oh this is some
secret operation and this and that and
it was undercover and nobody really knew
about it and their whispers like
i don't know maybe but the fact that
this is so
publicly available
and on the news right from the [ __ ]
get-go
why i mean i have a hard time saying
that there are any rogue agents doing
this well i i showed a clip earlier i
showed a clip earlier that clearly
showed newsmax reporting the breaking
news that there was an informant
an informant for the fbi i'm telling you
this is not this is not rogue agents the
informant is giving them information you
[ __ ] idiot and if steve scalise
wanted to cut this out which douchey is
trying to get him to do here douchey is
trying to do his best to to to put the
ball on the t for steve scalise to say
no this is a legal warrant it was
legally obtained there's no rogue agents
people need to stop with the nonsense
with the fbi i do support law
enforcement no matter where it may lead
and i hope that donald trump is a
criminal but i know he is that's what he
should say but let's listen to what the
opposite of what i just said is he gonna
say probably you know there were reports
yesterday that merrick garland said he
didn't even know about this raid i don't
know if anybody believes that but he
should be asked under oath if he knew
about the raid prior to it happening see
i would bet that mayor garland would
actually go on the road and answer that
question
i bet he would go under oath and answer
he wouldn't plea the fifth i know almost
a man
these people okay i just want to point
out someone's asking if i really think
it's barren no i don't really think it's
barren i'm making a joke here
but i you know hey who knows you know
anything is possible right anything is
possible in this world but yeah like
go under oath and say this stuff i would
love for these people to go under oath
and and commit on the record
that they believe
that there was some rogue agent team
that decided to execute the search
warrant that was signed by a republican
judge
which was issued by a republican fbi
director who was appointed by a
republican president former president
donald trump after he fired another
republican fbi director he's like i want
i want loyalty and conan's like nah [ __ ]
that [ __ ] not doing that right i want
loyal friends and he was like nope nope
nope i know what that's code for
and then he put in someone who he
thought was gonna do what he wanted to
do and turns out that republican
christopher wray actually is
you know pro-democracy and believes in
america and you know does his job as
he's supposed to so
i would uh again this is
all of these claims this is just [ __ ]
uh election 2020 fraud this is the
voting machines that's what this all is
this whole rogue team
raiding mar-a-lago it was a legal search
warrant issued by various republican
people that had their hands on it
crazy ass [ __ ] let's listen to more of
the [ __ ] uh he hasn't answered that
question why hasn't he held a press
conference why won't president obama
talk about his team why does he need to
relate to this guy
why does he need to as it related to
scott perry having his uh phone taken
away by fbi agents who came to his house
and said just give it to me uh uh where
he was they just took his phone
right
all right so the big thing you were
these are all things that are concerning
and by the way then they want to add 87
000 more irs agents right unrelated at
the same time
completely related completely different
[ __ ] agency
you know why they need to they need to
hire 87 000 agents because they can't
even answer their [ __ ] phones over
there at the irs so there's so people
have people are
there you know people who are just like
hey look i sent in my tax return and
like i haven't really heard anything
back right they're overwhelmed right not
only is it 2020 [ __ ] up the irs in
terms of returns that they had to do
because not only was that they're
issuing uh they're issuing um refunds
throughout the year
had to deal with extending
the submission deadline which was
extending the the extension deadline
then they had to fix it you know they
had new protocols in place because
people couldn't work in the office
anymore there was a lot of things that
[ __ ] up the irs and now we finally
have funding
and this is not to go after the middle
class this is to go after the people
that republicans want to protect which
are the rich and wealthy who found
loopholes
and other ways to make sure that they
don't pay that they're fair
well here's the thing is like
accountants offices like if you have an
accountant just call and ask the lady at
the desk or the your accountant himself
or or if the accountant tells you she
can she can tell you or people who work
there they can tell you
that they actually have several phones
in almost every accounting office that
ring through to the irs and they're
waiting on hold
there's no like special line for an
accountant's office to call the irs it's
all the same number so if they need to
ask a question about their clients they
actually let like four or five phones
ring and the first phone that picks up
from the irs they'll have all their
questions ready for that day and
sometimes it rings for four or five
hours or it sits on hold you know at the
elevator music for like four or five
hours until someone will pick up and
that's how they actually get someone on
the phone from the irs and accounting's
office so it's not that there's 87
agents to go out and kick down your door
and and run through your panty drawing
your safe the irs agents are there to i
don't know do the [ __ ] that the irs is
supposed to do and make sure that our
[ __ ] revenue service is operating
properly this is ridiculous i tried to
call i tried to call the irs to deal
with some taxes uh last week
and i was on hold for i don't know two
and a half hours so i was working and i
had the [ __ ]
that one music where it's like the the
the standard and what the people have
made memes about where they're like
like that music i i had to listen to
that for [ __ ] two and a half or three
hours just sitting here
listening to it i wonder why i can't
answer in my phone call yeah go straight
to voicemail and i still can't do this i
cannot i cannot have the possibility
that i'd take your call
and then that call says hello irs you
know or like i said
i clicked boom yeah done and then i
would have lost him that would happen
he's trying to call you the other day
and he was just completely sending me
straight but even more
yeah and the more important thing is
that 87 000 jobs the republican party
does not want to help create
87 000 jobs because the democrats put
forward a bill and they have that in
there and they're like whoa we want to
create jobs but we don't want to do it
if the democrats take credit well we
could both take credit if you guys
[ __ ] came
to the middle
and met us and voted on this
well the reason why we have this is
because we have congressmen
like steve scalise and scott perry who
are [ __ ] just absolute traitors um
scott perry got his cell phone seized
and you sent me this um
this video i guess this is on fox news
with kill amazing
amazing
okay let's let's this is only 22 seconds
so it's not it's not it's just a little
nugget just a little nugget your eyes on
what might be the best clip of the week
let's watch that they know he's coming
back and likely to beat their candidate
joe biden did you or any other candidate
did you get your phone back
did you get your phone back
congressman did you get your phone back
all right uh congressman scott perry
thanks we'll watch where you'll play
this back and you'll see i did thank you
that they know oh my god okay so so
they're talking about something
completely different here yeah
releasing the or un unleashing the doj
on trump right they're saying this is
this is the rhetoric this is firing up
people that go shoot excel
this is all about donald trump
unfairly getting his house searched or
raided as they said
uh and his things taken his sake was
broken into scott perry over here gets
his phone [ __ ] taken because he was
involved with talking about the
insurrection he also was seen by uh
um
or after a meeting with scott perry and
mark meadows she saw mark meadows
burning documents so you know this whole
idea of this is unfair it seems like
there is a reason to be suspicious about
certain people
and in this moment they're talking about
you know donald trump yeah yeah exactly
don't be suspicious
do you so let me ask you let me ask you
about this yeah because this is
hilarious this is great this is a great
piece of content here i am so happy that
fox news gave this to us sometimes they
just deliver the best things now
this this clip is
is
prepped what i mean by that is
someone on scott perry's team told him
if anyone asked you on live on air about
your phone you just act like the video
froze
right yeah like that it's cool like it
happens all the time it happens all the
time just free so let's do it gabe
and then it so you can make it
look like it
freezes i mean this is but this clearly
is
he like touches the earpiece you know
he's got in there and he's like he's
like oh okay like well that's just
that's after he blinks he blinks and
then he realizes
just blink to show me that you're
you're alive
well he blinked so he knew he [ __ ] up
the whole freezing thing yeah so that's
when he did the earpiece like also his
head you could see his head
you know slightly moving
attempting to act like it was
uh it was frozen right he's like can't
hear you can't hear you because the
whole idea is that this is unfairly his
phone was unfairly taken and if his
phone
was unfairly taken like it was it was
not
something that was justified it was
illegal
then his argument would be i would get
my phone back because they would have
they would have no proof of anything
right they would have no nothing to to
to pin on me to say that scott perry was
involved in trying to overthrow the
government with a coup on january 6th
but because he can't answer
his phone has not been given back
they're still looking through his
[ __ ] phone they're looking for the
digital footprints of what he's done any
communication between different people
they're connecting the dots between you
know this party and that party that
communicated in anticipation or during
january 6th
this is why he can't answer because they
still have it because they're still
[ __ ] going through it because it's
got stuff on it well let's watch this
one more time it's not very long but
it's worth a watch i'm gonna have to
watch this like 15 times a day let's
watch that they know he's coming back
and likely to beat their candidates
did you or any other candidate did you
get your phone back
did you get your phone back lick's lips
nervously blinked
congressman did you get your phone back
i guess we might have lost him
all right
you'll play this back and see i did
thank you i didn't thank you for coming
on to to not answer the question that i
wanted you to answer which was did you
get your phone back of course he didn't
get his [ __ ] phone back john eastman
hasn't got his [ __ ] phone back
jeffrey clark hasn't got his [ __ ]
phone back apparently uh robin keems
posting here that uh marjorie taylor
green a t and d turned over her phone
records um is that is that as of today i
i'm not sure i'm not sure because i
remember i i made a video
months ago about marjorie taylor green
and lauren bober trying to delete their
phone records because at t had been i
think at that point subpoenaed and i
would imagine that it was already turned
over at that point
oh
the records at that point yeah i was i
was under the impression that those
phone records had already been turned
over because if
there's probably
little to no reason that att would say
now we're going to hold on to it they're
probably like yeah
we don't want to be affiliated with
trying to protect this person whatever
our political stance is it's not worth
it right they already dropped oan
mj our great moderator one of our great
moderators her and robin both um she
points out garland is having a press
conference at 2 30. that must be eastern
time
um so that would be
about 30 minutes yeah 35 minutes so uh
steve scalise i don't know if you're
hearing this but you should go to that
press conference maybe you'll watch what
what a real
justice department
so mad they didn't throw a press
conference oh my god immediately and
here it is here's and now they are and
now he's like
what took him so long this was took him
so long this was he should have had a
press conference before he went into the
mar-a-lago right yeah he should have
warned donald trump to hide all his
stuff and get rid of all the evidence
before they went in there that way he
wouldn't uh be accused of crimes let's
watch this video to help those people
who donated to the election defense fund
only to have their money stolen by us
because the fund didn't actually exist
that's why we started a new fund the
fight the fraud fund to fight this seems
stolen
this seems stolen i'm not i mean uh
there's a little there's a little uh
imprint down here that says the late
show with stephen goldberg this isn't
the first time the first time what that
they stole your idea yeah remember the
u-haul uh patriot front one
yeah they did they stole the [ __ ]
u-haul idea yeah they did they did
so for anyone out there who's listening
to the show or seeing my content that's
writers for the colbert show that yeah
the latest show would be they got it
they got to have someone that's watching
this thing every day someone someone's
watching either this or my content i
don't know but either way i one i take
it as a compliment but two
stop stealing the [ __ ]
they hire me for it you know yeah they
can come and ask us and we'll we'll
you'll produce we'll produce we'll
produce content for him he'll i'll do
that yeah i mean we ain't get we ain't
we're gonna we ain't gonna charge nickel
and dimes we're gonna charge the [ __ ]
out of them now
hell yeah well i mean we got to get paid
for the last [ __ ] but this seems this
seems a little ripped just a little bit
so far maybe it changes maybe we're not
giving them the benefit of the doubt
let's find out the fraud of our first
fraud which admittedly was also a fraud
but due to those two previous frauds
we've never needed your money more
that's why we're coming to you loyal
trump supporters one last time with a
new fraud fighting fund to fight the
fraud of the fund created to fight
election fraud fraud
introducing the fight the fraud of the
former fight the fraud which fought the
fraud
well now i'm curious how does it end is
there something else like they had the
fraud to cover the first fraud and the
second fraud but i fee like you know
with comedy there's a rule of three so
right so maybe there's another one no no
i'm saying like you're not the end of
the video yet well let's well i know
that okay okay
well here's the thing is because they're
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
they're gonna knock us on this because
this is stephen colbert see they steal
the content they steal the content and
then they copyright it and then they
won't let us [ __ ] play it on our
youtube channel so more than likely
double dig dude right if you're watching
this and you're just like what video are
they talking about it's because i had to
cut the sh to cut the [ __ ] video out
of this episode on youtube so it's just
me and gabe talking as i pause it
so that's why i pause and we talk is
because there's fair use things and all
this [ __ ] but they're gonna copyright
this thing
and they're gonna have three or four
sections where i paused it but let's
watch the end and let's see if gabe is
right
donate generously together we can help
us by helping you help us to get your
money again and this time we promise no
fraud
okay that's that's right and someone
ripped it off for tic-tac anyways yeah
you know that's how it goes that's a you
know double
double rip off there what a what a way
to end the episode is to silence the
episode because they're going to
copyright it because they stole your
account well i i i'll say
it's a little bit different yeah yeah
they they heighten a little later they
say oh well the only way to cover the
fraud
is to you know make another fun for the
fraud
so whoever is out there watching this
content or our content or your content
with the uh with the late show stephen
colbert
you do a good job of not stealing the
whole thing yeah sometimes yeah
sometimes sometimes we'll have other
other jokes but the premise uh tomorrow
well i have so i made a quick side note
i made a video about a a maga dating
service and then that that that ryan
mcinanny kaylee mcinanny's uh yeah she
launched that website we ain't got a lot
of time left but i gotta go
go ahead yeah yeah so we can play
tomorrow don't don't play today we'll go
tomorrow on the show yeah okay good and
i'll play mine i'm also working on a
spoof video for that app instead of the
right stuff it's called the white stuff
oh
very good so everyone tune in tomorrow
because tomorrow's friday
so you know what you up friday's gabe
here on the tony michaels podcast
of the week
every single week we do bonehead of the
week on this in the second hour of the
show on friday so don't forget to go and
follow us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
you can vote there you can also vote
here on youtube gabe
and most the time when you put out the
poll most the time when you put out the
poll on twitter i try to get it up on
youtube as quickly as possible most of
the time most most of the time so you
can also vote here on youtube so
subscribe to the youtube channel so you
can
see who is the bonenet of the week
because you vote you decide you the
bonehead of the week and me and gabe
break it down on friday in the second
hour you can also download bonehead of
the week on sundays we cut that part out
we put it up on the directory so you can
download the tony michaels podcast seven
days a week on apple spotify google your
favorite directories leave us a great
review while you're there and do me a
favor
our mods are working so hard our
moderators are working so hard in the
chat again mj robin put your twitter
handles up there and chat everyone do me
a favor go follow robin midas robin and
go file mj
on twitter put your twitter handles in
there so they can find you easily go
follow them on twitter
and give them some love and some support
and if you also want to give the show
support you can go to
thetonymichaels.com the links in our bio
everywhere
just go to thetonymichaels.com at the
top of the page you can show your
support you can also go
find some merch and gabe before we go
we're working on some doubt me shirts
we're working on these goutman shirts so
everyone stay tuned the doubt me shirts
are coming they're coming coming coming
so go to the tonymichaels.com
go look at the merch now compared to
what the merch is going to be
because it's coming folks it's coming
show us yours and if you haven't uh and
if you haven't purchased a defund mtg oh
yes i showed that earlier yeah make sure
to it's it's a pin tweet on my profile
you can go to my store uh 50 of the
proceeds go to marcus flowers uh her
opponent running in georgia so i want to
make sure that uh everyone wears these
shirts before the election and after
well we'll see you guys tomorrow at the
same time same place noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
and twitch and simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page don't forget
to go vote for bonehead of the week
because tomorrow's friday week
tomorrow's friday and we're gonna we're
gonna surf the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends and go through the bone of
the week until then
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking